le rassemblement national un parti
banalisée en 20 ans à quel point pour le
voir comparons deux époques le 21 avril
2002 énorme surprise un de choc
jean-marie le pen candidat front
national déjoue les pronostics et se
qualifier pour le second tour de la
présidentielle
c'est une première pour le parti
d'extrême droite
partout en france plus d'un million de
personnes manifestent pour dire non au
fn je ne peux pas supporter l'idée que
un mec comme le pen puisse arriver un
jour pouvoir quinze ans plus tard en
2017 le front national est une nouvelle
fois au second tour d'une présidentielle
mais cette fois pas de front républicain
dans la rue les manifestations n'ont
rien à voir avec 2002 et marine le pen
n'est pas la seule candidate visé
le fn comme accro et un peu aussi contre
un peu le système tout entier qui est
capitaliste et qui ne contenant qui ne
me convient pas du tout autre élément de
comparaison les unes des journaux à
gauche celle du quotidien libération au
lendemain du premier tour en 2002 avec
un grand nom à droite le même journal
cette fois au lendemain du premier tour
en 2010 est la tonalité n'est plus la
même emmanuel macron s'affiche avec ce
titre à une marche pareil pour le figaro
à gauche ce titre fort en 2002 le séisme
à droite en 2017 de choc a déserté la
une du quotidien avec ces trois mots la
droite carreau mais alors comment le
rassemblement national s'est-il
banalisée en 20 ans c'est le résultat de
l'opération de dédiabolisation menée par
marine le pen en 2011 al accède à la
tête du fn un changement bienvenu selon
ce sympathisant elle est beaucoup plus
moderne et elle est beaucoup plus comme
on dit dans le vent c'est une nouvelle
génération cdc des idées
comment des idées présentes présenter
différemment marine le pen veut rompre
avec l'image de son père 2017 pour la
campagne présidentielle
elle change de logo le nom de le pen a
disparu autre élément de communication
finie la flamme du front national place
à une rose bleu sans épines la rose
évoque la gauche le bleu évoque la
droite disons que c'est le symbole aussi
du rassemblement du peuple français 2018
nouvelle étape dans la dédiabolisation
du parti fini le front national le parti
s'appelle désormais le rassemblement
national il y avait des personnes je
pense qu'ils avaient peur de se joindre
à notre mouvement alors qui a vraiment
pas lieu de s'inquiéter et on va pouvoir
rassembler plus de gens toute cette
stratégie de communication se ressent
aussi dans les élections notamment
présidentielle en 2007 pour sa dernière
campagne jean-marie le pen a récolté 3
millions huit cent trente quatre mille
cinq cent trente voix au premier tour en
2012 pour sa première élection
présidentielle marine le pen a obtenu 6
millions 421 1426 voix au premier tour
puis en 2010 7,7 millions 678 1491 voix
soit deux fois plus que son père dix ans
plus tôt
[Musique]